all right ted well this extreme heat is
certainly dangerous but it's also really
rough on our cars the nevada department
of transportation's freeway service
patrol says this time of year summer
their busiest time of year sasha loftus
rode along with them today as they help
those stranded on the side of our
roadways joining us now live sasha
brian when you break down on the highway
these are the people you call we rode
along with them today to see how you can
avoid some serious problems this summer
vegas rose blogging is 76. steven
sanfilippo is pretty good at saving the
day first responders first responder as
a nevada department of transportation
freeway service patrol supervisor he
drives up and down the i-15
stopping to help people strand it with
flat tires
overheated engines
no gas
or those involved in crashes so you know
it's these three for sure it also get to
help people which is definitely
satisfying in a city like las vegas
stephen is always on the go tire changes
time but the summer's extreme heat
brings a whole new slew of issues i
can't even put a number on it but
it's multiplied
quite a bit he says tires and hoses tend
to fail in triple digits he also sees
issues with low fluids make sure your
all your fluids whether that be your
coolant your oil
and your radiator as well
all that's topped off and as gas prices
soar more drivers push their tanks past
empty so i'll give you a gallon and get
you out of here man so before you get
stuck in this kind of situation make
sure your car is maintained and ready if
you get a vehicle that overheats and
shuts off
in this weather in turn you have no ac
to handle all the unbearable
temperatures
southern nevada throws our way this
season
[Applause]
this is a state-funded service so it's
free to drivers who need it if you need
help you can dial star 647 or in an
emergency of course style 9-1-1
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now